[Music]
ninja Lars gum centric approach to
combat isn't like anything you've played
before so it's understandable to feel a
bit overwhelmed the first time you
attempt a battle royale before you jump
into combat take heed of our guide to
ninja lar fundamentals and you'll be
well on your way to maxing out your s
energy and scoring major it pawns
against the competition fact ninja hates
staying grounded sure they can do it but
they'd much prefer to be running up and
along walls and dashing from rooftop to
rooftop ninja lar knows this all too
well and provides its kitty ninja cast
with huge multi-layered playgrounds
where they can run riot there's
absolutely nothing wrong with using your
first few games simply to get your
bearings and to better acquaint yourself
with navigating the environments using
all the tricks at your disposal
fortunately getting around is extremely
easy just running into walls is enough
for you to get vertical and you'll soon
get the hang of double jumping and using
the dodge to zip around quickly you've
also got the gum - which costs valuable
s energy but allows you to travel huge
distances in a heartbeat you should also
keep an eye out for bubble gum slides
long stretches of gum that you can jump
on to grind between buildings to go
farther even faster if you find that the
default settings are a little too
unorthodox and want something closer to
a traditional action game head to the
control settings and give type D a try
at launch ninjalah features 12 weapons
divided across three categories katanas
are all rounders hammers are slow and
smashy and yo-yos trade power for
striking range once you've picked a type
that broadly suits your style it's time
to dig deeper into the abilities of each
weapon because while standard attacks
are the same across weapons at the same
time they each offer a different mix of
special abilities the one you'll likely
use most in moment-to-moment combat is
gun shoot which is the projectile you
create when blowing a bubble for the
upon katana it's a single hit bubble
that fires off in a straight line while
the skate hammer creates a gun web that
causes chip damage to anyone unfortunate
enough to touch it specials are stronger
attacks managed by a cool-down system
and will trigger a state change on hit
such as a stun knock back or knock down
some like the skate hammers power Buster
have a big and very obvious wind-up but
deal huge damage while others are useful
for closing the gap in an instance such
as the yo-yos yoyo leap the final
consideration is gum ninjutsu the most
powerful attack in a ninjas arsenal the
ninjutsu gauge automatically fills at a
slow pace but can be accelerated by
landing hits once full you're on the
path to an almost guaranteed upon
possibly more than one if you play your
gun right again these vary wildly
between weapon types from devastating
gum tornados to long-range gum beams
that can pass through walls it's also
worth noting that weapons have inherent
abilities ranging from temporary super
armor after an upon to resetting the
cooldown gauge for your special if you
can avoid damage long enough the only
way to truly figure out which weapon
class and type suits you is through
experimentation but even then aim to be
as flexible and adaptable as you can
what might work best as a lone wolf in a
battle royale might not be what's best
for the group in a team battle
s energy or shinobi energy is the power
a ninja requires to perform critical
moves boost their abilities and most
importantly craft big weapons in a nod
to MOBAs your best move at the start of
a round isn't a head straight for your
rivals but rather to track down drones
and destroy them to boost your s energy
capacity from its default four units up
to a maximum of ten if you're feeling
particularly sneaky it's possible to gun
morph close to a drone let a rival do
all the hard work and then steal the
killer blow the s energy bar sits just
below your health but you can also get a
good idea of your status from the size
of the bubble you blow when holding Z L
if you're at six units your bubble will
be bigger and your air dashes will be
faster and at eight units and above your
global will be huge and you'll get a
prompt to create a bigger weapon having
more units also increases the number of
dodges and gun dashes you can perform in
succession the former costing one unit
and dash is costing three also note that
in team battle mode green drones have an
area of effect benefit so any nearby
teammates will also earn the same boost
to their s energy meter in short aim to
be the first to max out your s energy if
you want to be the fastest the deadliest
and wield the biggest weapon
ultimately ninjalah is a high school
contest so knowing how to stay top of
the table is essential pretty much
everything you do earns you points at
the lower end of the scoring spectrum
you can net a small amount by collecting
the s energy orbs dotted around the
arena's but it's when you start landing
hits that the points really rack up a
standard drone can net around 300 points
if you land every hit but the larger
tougher drones will earn you over 400
points but swatting down defenseless
drones will only take you so far if you
want to really start raking in the big
figures you'll have to master upon
finishes there's a few scenarios that
result in an upon the simplest way is to
ko someone with the gum ninjutsu but
they're achievable in standard combat -
if you first bind an opponent in gum
either by hitting them with a gum shoot
or crushing their gum guard with what's
known as a gum break then finish them
with a combo that also does the trick
you'll also get an opportunity if you
win a parry that's where two identical
attacks meet and trigger a showdown
that's akin to a rapid-fire game of
stone Paper Scissors using the left
stick try to remember that up beats down
down beat sideways and sideways beats up
when that follow up with a KO worthy
combo and you'll bag yourself an eight
pond if you both pick the same direction
you'll have to choose again until one of
you wins out and earns a nice bonus in
the process it's also possible to
trigger a parry by using an S burst
while you're being combo'd but this
takes up five units of s energy one
final crucial thing to be aware of is
that the game tracked the number of
drone takedowns and it pawns executed
during a match and awards big bonus
points to the best performers at the
results screen 504 the top drone
destroyer and 1,000 for the it pond
master that's enough to cause major
last-second upsets so try not to slack
on either front the final elements of
building your ultimate gun wielding
ninja is shinobi cards these are
unlocked using the ninja medals you earn
from online play and grant a variety of
enhancements such as the ability to
absorb an opponent's energy see the
position of drones through walls and say
when opponents are behind you cards must
be allocated to a slot to be activated
you'll have one to begin with but ninja
medals can also be spent to open up a
total of four slots shinobi cards also
have a points cost and as a cost cap to
prevent you from becoming opie although
that cap increases the more card slots
you have open each card also has a set
of three sub skills called assist codes
which are both unlockable and
upgradeable with you guessed it ninja
medals it's important to note that
shinobi cards cannot be acquired using
the purchasable currency jolla in order
to avoid a pay to win scenario think of
shinobi cards as a means of either
making your character even stronger as
an aspect of combat you're already
proficient in or a solution to
addressing a weakness in your skill set
with four slots opened up you'll have an
even greater opportunity to mix and
match your optimal setup hopefully this
short guide has armed you with the
knowledge you need to get out there and
show the world who's truly the world's
mightiest ninja and if you haven't
gotten in July yet don't forget that
it's exclusive to Nintendo switch and is
truly free-to-play you don't even need a
Nintendo online subscription to join the
fight